congratulations
thought the first three episodes were
great i cannot wait to see more
um uh jumping in and you know i'm about
to get geeky and stuff like that or ask
some specific [ __ ]
were you told that you couldn't use
like fantastic four x-men characters
that had not been
in the mcu were they like off-limits
uh it's a great question yeah we that we
had very few parameters uh
when we were idioting the show but that
was certainly one of them
we wanted to make sure that the
characters were firmly rooted in the
in the in the mcu and that wasn't that
nothing to do with rights and had
nothing to do with
with with the future stories we wanted
to tell
and it everything to do with what what
if is
which is a spin on an established
storyline
so we we we looked primarily at the
infinity saga so
so basically the second kevin and the
mcu make deadpool
the what if episode will be the
following year
well yeah once once it's once it's there
we get to make it
we got it uh the episodes are about 30
minutes long
was that the parameter that like
everyone came up with
did you guys discuss the possibility of
doing one that's a lot longer or
even like a what if feature film for
disney plus
we didn't think about format that's one
of the that's one of the um
that's one of the best things about
streaming actually is because it exists
on this service that's international
you know the old parameters of
particular lengths of time and
particular breaks in the story
uh go out the window so it's it's
actually very liberating but also very
scary because now you there
there's less rules um so we we targeted
you know a half an hour um for each
episode some of them come in a little
longer some of them come in a little
shorter
and really it was all about producible
time you know we wanted to tell as many
stories as we could
and we had a certain budget you know we
had to we had to work with so it
it was it felt like that that 10 episode
now nine episode run was the right was
the right uh
quantity wait so i thought it was ten
episodes is it now nine
yeah we had to push an episode into
season two
it was just honestly like everything
else that was a a covet impact
um there was an episode that just
wouldn't hit the um
the the the completion date so it's it's
it's it but luckily we do get to see it
uh in the second season of the show
so you're basically saying that season
two will be 11 episodes instead of
ten season two will also be nine
okay so it's 18 in total got it yes yes
so
i'm curious obviously you guys got like
85 of the marvel actors to do their
voices
was the hold up with tom holland a
result of his sony contract
did you try to get him you know i'm not
privy to all the ins and outs of the
relationship with sony um but uh
uh but i think it it may have had
something to do with it yeah
i'm curious and i think a lot of fans
are going to want to know did
you guys try to get chris evans and
scarlett
and dave batista or was it one of these
things where
because it's it's interesting that just
a few people that are not a part of it
we did try to get everybody you know um
we
we expected i mean
i expected maybe like i thought that 50
would have been
um a win if we had gotten you know
just half the people we asked to come
back the fact that we
got as many um people as we did to
reprise their voices
is really uh is really incredible
um you know and and and goes beyond my
wildest dreams
um you know yeah i don't i can't speak
to why certain people didn't come back
a lot of it was just scheduled conflicts
and people being busy on
various projects um but we also didn't
push you know like
you know we we wanted people to come in
and do it you know
enthusiastically on their on their own
terms i i completely get it
do you envision what if assuming that
everyone loves it and it's successful
do you envision it as a yearly series
like do you think season two is next
year
or is it gonna be like in every other
year type situation um
well as you know with animation it takes
a long time to produce
uh we are fortunate enough to get the
green light on the second season
um uh early enough to to to have it have
a chance to release it next year
um we'll see what happens obviously i
don't want to predict the future
in this new world we live in um but our
intention is to make it
a annual one of the things i actually
think that is a
side benefit of this series which
probably you didn't even think about
when making it
is the fact that look disney likes
selling merchandise marvel likes selling
merchandise
you can only make so many thor figures
but all of a sudden now what if
opens the door on all these alt versions
of all these characters
so is there sort of like someone in
merchandise realized oh my god this
could be amazing
yeah i mean certainly um it it was not
on our mind when we first conceived it
although you know very quickly we
realized that it would be really cool
you know it's hard not to like geek out
about what the hot toy might be you know
when you're like coming up with this
stuff um
uh uh and i just i do remember
distinctly like
you know when i was doing the rounds and
pitching the show to the to the
the cp folks for the first time they
were like over the moon
exciting
yeah no completely by the way because i
will totally get some of these and put
them behind me
oh man what an honor you know oh hey
listen i gotta rap i'm just gonna say
congrats and i'm really looking forward
to seeing the rest of the episodes
thank you so much stephen i really
appreciate it